johnny depp and amber heard once walked
down the aisle together but they're now
facing off in court in a real-life
hollywood legal drama
death pursuing her for 50 million
dollars for a 2018 opinion piece she
wrote about domestic violence which
actually doesn't mention the actor
she's counter-suing for 100 million
dollars
and yesterday the court heard more about
their disputes
one of which was seen firsthand by the
estate manager of depth private island
who spoke via video call you could hear
inside the house
yelling
um
her amber yelling and johnny answering
back and you could really hear what was
being said amber was telling him that he
was a
washed-up actor
he was going to die a lonely fat lonely
old man
the spotlight then shifted to herd's
mental state a depth witness concluded
she had multiple personality disorders
traits she said often spiral into
attempts to avoid being abandoned the
results of misheard's evaluation
supported two diagnoses borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder she also cast doubt
on herd's claim she suffered ptsd
symptoms the actress maintains are
caused by her relationship with depp i
very specifically um was assessing to
determine whether post-traumatic stress
disorder was present and it was not
we've heard from depp and an array of
witnesses but heard has not had her
chance to respond
she's set to testify later in the trial
shinki mararike sky news